dans le même temps jean louis debré le
ministre de l'intérieur effectué une
tournée dans le rhône dans le vaucluse
avec deux sujets à l'ordre du jour
l'insécurité et l'immigration reportage
fluence bouquillard jacques garnich bien
pressés au hit-parade les soutiens de
campagne les plus demandés le ministre
de l'intérieur
une cinquantaine de candidats à la
députation se l'arracha faute de temps
entre son boulot de ministre et sa
propre circonscription jean louis debré
a élu une petite vingtaine de chansons
comme ici dans le rhône ou d'emblée les
commerçants antonin a reconnu celui de
la sécurité nous ont pris 120 mille
francs en 00h01 quand même des tabacs
savoir il faut expulser depuis depuis
deux ans nous avons renvoyé hors de
france
27000 personnes et nous en avons
empêchés de rentrer près de 48 et il
faut faire ça pendant au moins cinq ans
encore pour arriver à un peu près de de
stabilité partout même thème de campagne
à la duchère cités réputées difficiles
dans la banlieue lyonnaise feront sur et
jean louis debré me rencontrer des
jeunes bonjour ribery à la télé là tu es
sans parler de vous un peu c'est dire
moi non échantillons j'aime par exemple
à paris
la nationale ou oui mais sa marge ans il
faut se tenir tranquille c'est une
démocratie justement la démocratie
repose sur le respect de la loi et du
respect pour intimider les uns rassurer
les autres l'ambition de ce marathon de
campagne dans le rhône le vaucluse puis
le garde toute terre de prédilection du
front national auquel jean louis debré
pense toujours sans jamais le citer
nous ne pouvons pas donné non plus le
gouvernement de la france à l'extrémisme
car l'extrémisme on sait toujours où ça
commence on ne sait jamais où ça finit
oui je crois qu'il ne faut pas tomber
dans le piège du socialisme pas plus
qu'il faut tomber dans le piège de
l'extrémisme un piège que jean louis
debré tente de déjouer en fauchant les
mêmes chevaux de bataille que le front
national